so what can a few minutes of unplanned
downtime cost a business
six or seven figures in lost revenue a
damaged brand
regulatory action hi my name is albert
traylor
and i'm with ibm cloud and today i'm
here to talk about
artificial intelligence for operations
also known
as a i ops
so before we go into the definition of
ai hops let's think about a scenario
imagine that you are an it operations
professional
at a successful real estate company
let's call that company
housing for all
at h4a you support a portfolio
of applications one of which is an
invoicing application
used by tens of thousands of partners
every day
for this specific application your focus
is to
make sure it's up and that and that
partners can deliver
invoices consistently on it on a regular
basis
one day you settle into your desk you
get a cup of coffee
and you get a phone call just like that
out of nowhere a sales rep is calling to
complain
that a partner is trying to upload an
invoice and has been unable
to all morning because the application
is down
what do you do in that scenario to get
this application back up and running
so before we continue down that scenario
let's talk about aiops and the textbook
definition
artificial intelligence for operations
is about the application of artificial
intelligence
machine learning models and opera and
advanced analytics
to i.t operational data the objective
is to empower it professionals and
operations
professionals with the data they need to
make decisions
and ultimately resolve and restore
service to an application
faster so
with that definition in mind let's talk
about how we can get this invoice
application
back up and running now let's think
about
the the key data sources for our
invoicing application
let's start with events and metrics
logs alerts
and a few others but for now let's focus
on these as the data sources
for our specific invoicing application
in the real world this will look
different depending on your application
architecture
the type of data sources that are
applicable for your application
and data regulatory requirements so
we've got our key data sources now how
does this fit into our model
for ai ops let's think about three key
steps
the first one we're going to call
monitor
and discover
so in this first step the data is
ingested by the ai ops platform
and is thresholded and created and
creates baselines for your specific
application
so let's think about it this way what is
normal for my invoicing application
what is the log ingestion rate how many
errors is acceptable based on our slo
or service level objective so we now
have that information
the next step of the process is about
engage
and context
so the next step is engage in context so
this is where ai ops really shines
it takes all of that ingested data and
it services
it to an i.t operations professional or
site reliability engineer
in the form of a collaboration solution
also known as chat ops
so up until now everything's been done
in the background and as soon as this
incident pops up with our invoicing
application
it surfaced via chat ops to our site
reliability engineer
less is more here they have the context
on where the incident is located in the
application
what specific actions are recommended to
resolve this
and most importantly how are those
actions based on
incidents like this that have come up in
the past
so now our sre is armed with that
information
and it's our last phase which is act
and automate
so everything's been done in the
background this information
has been surfaced to our it officer sre
itops professional sre and then finally
we have to act
and automate to resolve this issue
the suggested options that are available
via chat ops
enable the itops to select what has
worked in the past
and with a click activate a script or
run book to resolve this issue
as soon as it's detected this gets our
invoicing application back up and
running faster
and make sure that our partners are
happier in with this experience
so now we've got the overview three key
steps
the type of data that's ingested by ai
ops
in summary this system allows its
professionals to solve problems faster
to keep applications up and running and
help protect the business in the long
run
thank you if you have any questions
please drop us a line below
if you want to see more videos like this
in the future please like and subscribe
and don't forget you can grow your
skills and earn a badge with ibm cloud
labs
which are free browser-based interactive
kubernetes
labs